pour les 1000 et 10 mille pardons
chasseurs de corse une petite centaine
sont des femmes à l'initiative de la
fédération départementale de la corse du
sud elles ont décidé de se regrouper au
sein d'une association appelée la diane
association d'une vingtaine d'adhérentes
aujourd'hui samedi dernier elles étaient
une dizaine sur le terrain pour la
première sortie officielle de
l'association
une battue administrative dans la région
de cazals a brief le soleil est élevé
depuis deux bonnes soeurs quand tout ce
beau monde s'est retrouvé au dessus de
petreto les hommes sûrs de leur fait et
un peu rieurs les femmes encore timides
dans leurs tenues de campagne impeccable
le fait chasser n'exclut pas une
certaine élégance
on traîne un peu les chiens
s'impatientent pour une fois les hommes
joueront les rabatteurs tandis que les
femmes tiendront les postes un plan de
bataille est dressé on fourbit les armes
le sanglier n'a qu'à bien se tenir
[Musique]
vous en avez vous cite celle là auraient
fraîcheur du sous-bois ces dames suivant
les instructions de ces messieurs fort
instruire les choses ont rejoint leur
poste tandis que dans la vallée
les chiens ont commencé leur travail
[Musique]
cette étude a pour toi vais pas le
sentiment qu'on regarde un peu les
femmes chasseresse avec un petit sourire
moqueur n'ont pas pas chez moi je suis
le seul qui chassent tonnes
l'équipe de cette région un poteau mais
au contraire il me pende de tout à fait
comme copains alors je suis chrétien
comme ils m'ont accepté mais j'ai fait
beaucoup de la chasse au loup pas là
après deux heures d'une attente
infructueuses pour ces dames ponctué
dans le lointain du cris des chiens et
de quelques coups de feu le maître de
céans battra le rappel de la petite
troupe les pieds gelés les enrichit d'un
grand bol d'air face à la bête sauvage
puissante et dangereuses qu'elles n'ont
jamais vu ces dames en attendant mieux
contenu courageusement leur position les
femmes à la chasse participent
maintenant comme dans toute association
on les voit de partout ce sont elles qui
sont laids je dirais les médiateurs les
régulateurs un petit peu de la chasse
on les trouve partout il faut elles font
partie de la vie est là il faut les
intégrer les insérer et il n'y a pas de
raison qu'une femme avec un fusil
ne fasse pas comme un homme est tombé
tellement dans tempérament en corse
surtout quand il s'agit de s'ennuyer
c'est à dire que
tout évolue y compris y compris la femme
à la chasse on vous présente souvent sur
des gravures des femmes avec des fusils
ce n'était pas uniquement pour l'avant
d'être 7 également pour la chasse nous
savons qu'il y en a une cinquantaine par
département active mais il y en a
certainement davantage et c'est d'abord
de regrouper et d'inciter aussi les
jeunes à faire partie de cette
association est de venir se manifester
toutes les fois qu'il y à une chasse
débattu des questions génération nations
entre hommes chasseurs c'est une
tradition ici dans l'île et femmes
chasseurs ça se passe bien ça se passe
très bien quand vous l'avez vu ce matin
il n'y a pas de problème particulier
tout se passe bien il n'y a pas un petit
sourire au l'epr donc en tout cas fusil
non non ils sont habitués à nous voir et
contraire nous ont très bien acceptée
tout temps d'ailleurs je ne sont pas nos
premiers essais il y a il ya eu déjà
depuis de nombreuses années les femmes
qui ont chassé tout est pour le mieux
dans le meilleur des mondes ces dames
porteront la bête tuée par ces messieurs
avant de partager en commun un copieuse
painting le seul à ne pas s'être
interrogé sur l'origine de la balle qui
l'a frappé à la tête
c'est bien le pauvre sangliers
[Musique]